well after close to you know close to 20
hours of questions from senators in the
judiciary committee the question and
answer phase of supreme court nominee
judge katanji brown jackson are finally
over those hours are finally over that
portion has ended
and she will most likely be confirmed as
she should because as i outlined
yesterday she is more qualified by the
standard definitions to be on the
supreme court than any of the nine
justices currently on the court but this
doesn't mean that republican senators on
the judiciary committee didn't pull out
every possible dirty trick in the book
that they could think of
and unfortunately
a lot of these tactics were effective
this morning i appeared on the
right-wing daily wire show hosted by
michael knowles
and his and his audience think that it's
been incredible what ted cruz has done
what marsha blackburn did by saying can
you define woman and on and on and on so
she'll be confirmed and she should be
but these rhetorical uh
pond scum techniques
really do work and i want to look at a
couple more from yesterday at one point
trying to again draw judge jackson into
one of these rhetorical black holes
on identity
ted cruz went down a line of questioning
where he said could i choose to be asian
for an hour
and then go back to being hispanic take
a look at this and and again
the right loved this stuff but the
question
let me ask under the modern leftist
sensibilities if if
i decide right now that that i'm a woman
then
apparently i'm a woman does that mean
that i would have article 3 standing to
challenge a gender-based restriction
senator to the extent that you are
asking me about um
who has the ability to bring lawsuits
based on gender those kinds of issues
are working their way through the courts
and i'm not able to comment on them okay
if if i can
change my gender if i can be a woman and
then an hour later if i decide i'm not a
woman anymore i guess i would lose
article 3 standing now remember that all
of these
sometimes mild and sometimes more
extreme instances of transphobia
they're all based on imaginary worlds in
which people would do this you know i
don't want to get off on it we're going
to get back to ted cruz taking an hour
to be an asian man in a second but i
think it's important to remember that
with all of these things about bathrooms
and what if i put out someone uh the
other day left a voicemail asking me
about what if i put on a wig so that i
can then go into the women's room
it's still against the law to harass
people or to stalk people or
whatever and the idea that people are
going around trying to figure out how
can i spend a really long time in
bathrooms out in public the this is not
fortunately this is not actually the way
people operate in the world
and when people do have nefarious goals
uh for things they want to do to others
in bathrooms it doesn't matter quote
whether you're wearing a wig
or the gender of your identity it we we
have rules against treating people
certain ways and these are all red
herrings but let's continue
tell me does that same principle apply
to other protected characteristics for
example i'm i'm an hispanic man could
could i decide i was an asian man would
i have the ability to be an asian man
and challenge harvard's discrimination
because i made that decision hmm
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um i'm asking you how
you would assess standing if i if i came
in and said i have decided i identify as
an asian man now of course this is such
a bad it's ignorant or bad faith i don't
want to call it one if it might be the
other but when it comes to the court and
if she's interviewing here for a role as
a supreme court justice we should think
about how these issues are dealt with by
a court and courts have to decide
extremely narrowly based on the facts of
a particular situation and the complaint
of the party bringing
the case and the idea that we just need
to vaguely define whether ted cruz could
be asian for an hour uh is it
it's very stupid and it's not based in
reality now ted cruz also criticized
judge jackson because she didn't answer
what it means what the definition of
woman is which i think you're the the
only supreme court nominee in history
who's been unable to answer
the question what is a woman now i went
back and looked and i've not found any
other supreme court nominee in history
who was asked to please define a woman
so just bad faith trash all over we'll
look at one more clip
radical republican south carolina
senator lindsey graham
he stormed out on the first day of
questions he also did it yesterday after
making a bunch of other bad faith
arguments check this out your view of
how to deter child pornography
is not my view i think you're doing it
wrong and every judge who does what
you're doing is making it easier for the
children to be exploited if you're on a
computer right now looking at a kid and
sexually compromising situation and you
get caught i hope nobody gives you a
break because you use the computer
the conduct that's been described is
reprehensible and i think everyone in
this room agrees
and the fact of the matter is that i'm
co-sponsor of your bill the earned act
and i believe that we should be doing
our job here but part of our job we have
failed in responding to the changing
circumstances that face this crime what
has it been 15 or 16 years
she is currently not an outlier in
sentencing 70 of the federal judges face
the same dilemma and wonder why congress
has failed to act and when it will act
this is our fault pardon partially it is
senator to be honest with you it is
we have to upgrade these guidelines and
decide whether we're going to stick with
the supreme court decision that they're
not mandatory
senator feinstein thank you very much um
mr chairman and then out goes lindsay
storming out once again so listen here's
the what it fundamentally comes down to
judge jackson is more qualified
than anybody currently on the court
based on her experience and we looked at
it yesterday sentencing commission
judge at different levels etc etc they
don't have anything they've got nothing
on her and so this is what they've done
focus on uh issues that um are
completely separate from uh the way that
a supreme court actually evaluates uh
standing and facts of cases and to
grandstand in this way and they're
pathetic and she deserves to be
confirmed and i believe she will be
major breaking news this this is this is
absolutely huge
the prosecutor
who resigned recently from the trump
criminal probe
now says
that trump is guilty of numerous
felonies beyond a reasonable doubt
this is not
uh
i'm gonna pat myself on the back story
but
it sort of is in the sense that
when we learned that these prosecutors
resigned from the trump probe
right-wingers everywhere were saying
they resigned because they realized it
was a witch hunt
and at the time i said there's no
evidence of that and if we want to
speculate it seems more plausible to me
that the prosecutors investigating trump
resigned because they realized there's
not actually any willingness to charge
the guy
and they found wrongdoing
that is exactly
what one of the prosecutors now says
this story cannot be cannot be
understated in its importance
former manhattan prosecutor believed
trump was guilty of numerous felonies
one of the prosecutors who had been
leading the manhattan district
attorney's investigation into former
president trump and the trump
organization said in his resignation
letter that he believed trump was quote
guilty of numerous felony violations per
the new york times his financial
statements were false and he has a long
history of fabricating information
relating to his personal finances lying
about his assets to banks the national
media counterparties and many others
including the american people this is
mark pomerantz who wrote this in his
resignation letter
the team that has been investigating
trump harbors no doubt about whether he
committed crimes he did
i and others have advised you that we
have evidence sufficient to establish
trump's guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
and we believe that the prosecution
would prevail if charges were brought
and the matter were tried to an
impartial jury
no case is perfect whatever the risks of
bringing the case may be i am convinced
that a failure to prosecute will pose
much greater risks in terms of public
confidence in the fair administration of
justice
this is one of the biggest stories
around presidential wrongdoing and
criminality in decades in decades and
the right is ignoring it
pomerantz also expressed his concerns
that not proceeding would doom future
efforts at prosecuting trump in related
cases guys i hate to be i i know it
sounds like i'm patting myself on the
back
but
they were just so wrong and my
speculation turned out to be not just
pointing in the right direction
it is exactly what pomeranz is saying
took place this is exactly what he says
is going on
we suspected
there is serious hesitation
from
da's
to be the first to prosecute a former
president
my prediction was if one prosecution
went forward
then a whole bunch of others would
but
who wants to be the first because
admittedly this is politically unstable
ground
and it is historically unstable ground
and it's a big deal to charge a former
president i get that
but my
sense was
that these investigators were resigning
not because there was no evidence and
they were being forced to put together a
case against trump
but my instinct was they're resigning
because they're they're realizing their
work is going to be put in the toilet
and flushed
10 to 15 times as donald trump likes to
say
um they were finding wrongdoing and
these are extraordinarily strong words
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt that we
would be able to clearly establish in
front of a jury of the commission of
multiple felonies
when did we last hear prosecutors speak
that way about the actions of a sitting
or former sitting president
it is arguably unprecedented and they
realize my boss isn't going to charge
trump he's not going to do it so what
the hell am i doing here doing this work
what we do know
is they are hesitant about charging
trump and and that i understand that
but we now know the real reason why they
resigned
and it is exactly
exactly
what i suspected was going on
if there is a miscarriage of justice
here
it's that trump has not been charged
i want to hear from you find me on
twitter at deepakman let me know your
thoughts
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is not only buoyed
by but depends on the support of our
viewers and our listeners you can sign
up for a david pakman show membership at
joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code wow22
to get a discount if you so please we
actually do an extra show every day
for our members and i would love to see
you in membership ranks listen this is
completely beyond parody a former trump
advisor named larry kudlow and a
right-wing media host named mark levin
were uh
bemoaning that joe biden never
criticizes vladimir putin and this was
within uh just a couple days of joe
biden saying that vladimir putin is a
war criminal now the the story here for
me is projection we've talked about
projection before and with modern
trumpism one of the things we always
have to at least suspect is
if they accuse the left of something
we should look really deeply at whether
they are actually doing it themselves
when they said well the left doesn't
hillary and the left don't take care of
sensitive information
they can't be trusted
uh they're using private email
we should have said and some of us did
they're probably doing it right and
indeed jared kushner and ivanka trump
were using private email and donald
trump was eating and flushing and
burning
classified documents including stuff
that was supposed to be kept as part of
the presidential records act taking
documents to mar-a-lago etc so they were
really doing it um we
spent six months before the 2020
election with them saying oh the left is
is going to commit fraud as donald trump
would say
and it turned out they tried to commit
the fraud they tried to steal the
election they insisted that joe biden
actually stole it so when they say x is
going on what we should interpret that
as is you might be the ones doing x and
the idea of hey listen the election was
definitely rigged we should know we're
the ones who rigged it so of course now
the new thing is becoming why won't
biden criticize putin which of course in
reality the problem has been
these soft and not so soft
putin apologists on the right so in
comes larry kudlow and he says to uh
mark levin why doesn't biden just come
out and criticize vladimir putin it's
beyond parody let's take a look at it
let me ask you some just about putin
crazy putin um who is a criminal he's an
international war criminal but
why is it mark you and i
both worked in the reagan administration
i never hear biden
attack putin
so
kudlow literally says he's a war
criminal and that biden never attacks
putin here is biden calling putin a war
criminal for the invasion of ukraine
[Music]
i think he is a war criminal
um these guys are living in a fantasy
world let's continue historically
and criticize putin and his system and
his uh war criminality the way reagan
did to various communist leaders what
has biden been doing it's your former
boss who first said putin's genius
and savvy
and clever
and he's getting great land by what he's
doing
and then had to walk it back
and even when walking it back
he continued to um uh
make a very very soft criticism remember
during that weird
uh rally the rally that trump did in uh
where was this one this one i guess this
one was south carolina i don't even
remember where he talked about putin is
driven to put it together no he's
invading another country driven to put
it together listen to this
and for all the talk about violent
conflict in eastern europe and it's a
terrible thing and we're gonna help and
we're gonna do whatever we can because
nobody can look at the bloodshed much
longer what's happening right it's a
lack of respect
for a lot of people it's a lack of
respect not not exactly a strong
condemnation of vladimir putin a lot of
things but it's just a total lack of
respect
and it happens to be a man that is just
driven he's driven to put it together
and you look at it and it's just so
ridiculous that's uh not really a very
strong strong condemnation of putin
right he's just he's a man who's
driven to put it together uh well biden
called him a war criminal
so as usual we have to look
at their side when they accuse the left
of whatever in this case it's why won't
biden
more seriously criticize vladimir putin
and of course the real concern is the
putin apologists which included trump
although i guess now he's not although
who knows he's still using really
strange language like he's driven to put
it together uh people like tucker
carlson
etc etc you guys know the list and as
usual it is merely projection
i genuinely don't know at this point in
time
what is the belief of stephen bannon
about something they called the
certification decertification is a word
that bannon and people like my pillow
ceo mike lindell we we just know him as
pillow um what have they been
uh what how seriously do they believe
that states can or might decertify the
2020 election results this is not going
to happen we're almost at the next
election but steve bannon continues to
talk about it so i want to play this
clip for you people who are watching
might realize steve bannon is a just a
spitting image of b arthur at this point
it's a very very strange physical
appearance of steve bannon and that's
sort of out of school i don't really
know what to make of it but let's focus
in on what steve bannon says here listen
to what he says
of these electors and that's what
remember let's get our language very
specific
we're not asking and we've never asked
for president trump's never asked for it
this movement's never asked for it to
change the election and to flip it to
donald j trump that is just not the
right nomenclature it's not the right
language
what we've asked for is very similar
that only certifiable
constitutional
legal chain of custody votes from
american citizens can be counted for the
november 2020 election now of course
that's exactly what happened there has
been no evidence that votes that should
not be counted were counted so so far
i'm with bannon only valid votes should
be counted and we have evidence that
only valid votes were counted good
once they're counted right in an
accurate way
and real votes not things that came with
their machines although i'm not a
machine guys people know but once we get
everything remember mike pillow wants to
sue all machines
okay that's the election and we know now
whether it is in pennsylvania whether it
is in uh whether it's in wisconsin
arizona or georgia those four states
alone
we understand right now and i think
eventually nevada nevada and michigan
but those four states alone we can move
right now the state legislature to
decertify to decertify the electors not
to flip the election to decertify the
electors and do what the constitution
says flip it to the house of
representatives where you vote by uh you
vote by delegation state by state and of
course we control what 26 or 27 of those
delegations okay so again
bannon is saying
states can say our electors weren't
valid
and then
you instead of going by
electoral votes
each state gets one vote for who should
be president 26 states out of 50 will
say we believe trump and then trump
becomes the president this is not going
to happen first of all
we are almost at the next election
what is it now uh eight months seven and
a half months from the midterms but
putting that aside
everything bannon says in this clip is
untrue and i don't know if bannon really
believes what he's saying there is no
legal basis to uh decertify
um a state's election or electors
there's just
it's just not a thing
there is no provision in the united
states constitution that says
if states quote decertify their electors
then anything happens joe biden is
president to remove joe biden he would
need to die
um the 25th amendment could be used
or he could be
convicted on impeachment
those are the three ways that you can
quote remove the president and in any of
those three situations the vice
president would assume the presidency
so
what bannon is talking about doesn't
exist
and the most important consideration
here is imagine that even though there
is no such process as the the
decertification imagine some state
invented it and created it
if a state did it and again what it what
it means isn't even clear but if a state
were to decertify now in march almost
april of 2022
it would have no legal significance it's
not like even if you go and follow this
imagine that four states call up who do
you even call i guess you call up the
senate i don't even know who do you tell
you call someone in dc
and you say
sirs and mams we've decertified our
election from our electors from 2020.
you think washington dc goes oh okay
well let's just redo this thing and
we'll have each state get one vote of
course not there is no such process and
it's not
in the electoral account act of 1887
um it has no provision for
decertification that uh the for the 1887
legislation or or
structure on which this is all based so
again my question to you is do you think
steve bannon really believes any of this
stuff uh make sure that you see these
clips on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow it's great to welcome to
the program today daniel pink who's the
author of five new york times
bestsellers including the latest the
power of regret how looking forward
moves us i'm sorry how looking backward
moves us forward uh published last month
daniel it's great to have you on today
hey thanks for having me
so uh i read the book with great
interest and the book both
confirms some of the intuition that we
may have about regret and also and also
tells us that some of the intuitions we
have about regretter are very very wrong
maybe to start with can you talk a
little bit about
when it comes to the idea of it's just
better to live without regrets which is
a very general principle that a lot of
people assume is just accurate can you
talk a little bit about what aspects of
that make sense and and maybe where it
falls short
well it's a i mean it's a great way to
frame the question
there when we when we look we have this
idea that we should never look backward
and that we should if we feel a sphere
of regret we should essentially ignore
that um and that is
actually colossally
wrong-headed advice
what the research tells us what 50 years
of science tells us is that everybody
has regrets regret is one of the most
common emotions that human beings have
it is ubiquitous in the human condition
it is actually part of our cognitive
machinery and so to say that i don't
look backward and i don't experience
regret runs against the science it's
just simply not how human beings operate
um so
and the truth of the matter is that
everybody you know regret regret makes
us human um nearly everybody experiences
regret i mean literally except for a
very small number of people with certain
kinds of disorders everybody experiences
regret um and if we use it right it's
actually useful to us um and this is the
paradox of regret this is sort of the
puzzle of regret which is that this
emotion that makes us feel bad is
ubiquitous in the human experience so
why and the answer is because it helps
us if we deal with it right and we
haven't been equipped to
deal with regret properly we've been
taught in some ways to ignore it when
that fails we end up getting captured by
it and what we should be doing is
confronting our regrets yeah you talk in
the book about and this doesn't seem
unique to feelings of regret but in the
book you talk about how if the thoughts
of regret become
intrusive if they become
um sort of bottomless if they become
repetitive
that they end up having a sort of
counterproductive impact and it's not
but that thinking about the regrets in
particular ways and using them
is actually something that that is a
positive thing can you talk a little bit
about the difference between that
because some people might say well if
i'm not thinking about the regrets then
how can i use them to my advantage
well so that's great another great
another great question so it's really
i think at a broader level we haven't
been taught how to deal with negative
emotions um i think our religious
traditions actually do a better job of
equipping us to deal with negative
emotions i think secular society hasn't
done a very good job and so what happens
is that some of us ignore negative
emotions we say nope not real gotta be
positive
put our fingers in the ears that's a bad
idea uh but because we haven't been
equipped to deal with them when we do
when they intrude as you say uh they can
feel overwhelming and so we have to ask
ourselves this question about like what
are these negative feelings for they're
not for ignoring they're not for
wallowing they're for thinking about um
and they're for thinking about as you
say in a particular way and there's a a
certain process by which we can think
about our emotions and arrest that march
toward rumination arrest that march
toward getting sucked into the into the
vortex um and it's actually relatively
simple and when we do that the evidence
is is overwhelming that that reckoning
with our regrets leaning into our
regrets in some ways can help us become
better negotiators better strategists
better problem solvers better parents
and find greater meaning in life
you know it's interesting that our
interview is today and yesterday it just
so happened that during these supreme
court confirmation hearings um
particular sentences that the nominee
judge jackson had assigned in the past
were a topic of much discussion and she
was asked numerous times do you regret
the sentence you gave to this particular
individual who went on to reoffend or or
whatever the case may be and one of the
interesting things about that framework
is that it's sort of sort of like a
results-based regret where at the time
that you that a decision is made you
don't have the information as to what
subsequently happens and the question
was based on what happened after you
decided do you regret what you did and
daniel kahneman has written about this
and in the context of it being sort of a
a cognitive limitation that we sometimes
experience can you talk a little bit
about results-oriented
thoughts about regrets
yeah i mean i i don't want to legitimize
those questions about sentencing as as
serious intellectual inquiries agreed
100 they were they were yeah uh it was
basically performative grandstanding and
dog whistles um absolutely so by leaving
leaving that aside for leaving that
aside for a moment and i know i know
that you agree with that
um yeah well i mean
this is actually there are a couple ways
at this one of them is as we were
talking about before that's a way to
arrest the march toward rumination that
is what you need to evaluate is the
decision itself not the the not what
happened subsequently because the
decision itself is something you had
control over what happened subsequently
is something you don't have control over
um and so what i found in talking to
people about their regrets is they were
actually much less outcomes than i would
have expected um that they were actually
scrutinizing that
especially when it came to a certain
kinds of regrets they were much more
willing to scrutinize the decision
itself and were less wedded to the
outcome now all of us have that
all of us have that cognitive glitch but
but uh what's important to understand
with with regret is that when we
evaluate our choices and when we try to
extract lessons from them we should be
evaluating the context of the decision
what we knew what situation we were in
who in some ways who we were as a person
at that moment um and
because that's something we have control
over but the outcome itself we don't
always always have control over although
the outcome does you know can give us
clues
you um in the book you categorize
regrets into sort of certain buckets
and
in that context you did this world
regret survey of 15 000 people in in
more than 100 countries can you talk
about the categories of regret that seem
to be the most impactful for people when
they look back on their lives
yeah i mean what what i found in in
collecting regrets from all over the
world as you mentioned we're now up to
over 19 000 uh regrets from over from
109 countries it's unbelievable um and
what i found which is to my surprise is
that over and over again people had the
same core regrets they regretted the
same things and these regrets were less
about the domains of people's lives they
were less about oh i have a career
regret i have an education regret i mean
superficially that's what they were but
deep down there were four things that
people
seem to regret the most i'll go through
them very quickly one of them are what i
call foundation regrets foundation
regrets are if only i'd done the work
and these are regrets about small
decisions people make about health about
finances about education early in life
that
accumulate to
you know sometimes very grave
consequences later on um so things about
especially things like not saving enough
money spending too much money uh smoking
those kinds of things second one are
boldness regrets which are if only i
taken the chance these are regrets
people have where they're at a juncture
in their life they can play it safe they
can take the chance and they don't take
the chance and they often regret it
and it's everything from traveling to
speaking up to asking somebody out on a
date to starting a business and what's
interesting about those david is that
um
there were people who acted boldly
and it didn't work out
and many of them said
i don't love that but i'm cool with that
because i took the chance so that's a
good example of what you were talking
about before people being to my surprise
being less outcomes than i would have
expected
third category if only i done the right
thing these are people who again are at
a juncture they can do the right thing
they can do the wrong thing they do the
wrong thing they regret it bullying
marital infidelity other kinds of
cheating and finally our connection
regrets which are if only i'd reached
out which are about relationships um not
mostly romantic relationships just the
full spectrum of relationships we have
in our lives that if they come apart
and we don't do anything about it we end
up regretting it and and what's amazing
to me
in this research is that
is how universal
these four regrets were i mean
irrespective of you know of um of
nationality especially uh pretty much
irrespective of gender
and to some extent even irrespective of
age
are there certain cultures or countries
that just have a lower level of regret
in your estimation
i don't know that's an interesting
question um i tried to get at that i
tried to get out that question in in a i
did another piece of that so the the
world record survey was a piece of
qualitative research that as i was
essentially collecting stories i also
did a piece of quantitative research
which was a um which essentially a giant
opinion poll of the american population
the largest
uh sampling of american attitudes about
regret ever conducted a pretty rigorous
quantitative survey and i tried to get
at that
a version of that question that way by
asking say
about say belief in god does a belief in
god correlate with people's regrets
zero correlation of any kind i ask
people do you give people three choices
do you believe in god
which of these best describes your
belief i believe in god i don't believe
in god i'm not sure i believe in god and
zero correlation of any kind with
with anything um i also asked people
whether they believed that in general
everything in life happened for a reason
and
most people did yet most people also
believe they had free will so
so so other ways at that question about
belief systems seem to indicate there
there wasn't much difference i mean i'm
not i'm i'm hesitant to to say that def
i'm very hesitant to say that
definitively my hunch right now is that
that
the that that belief systems didn't
matter all that much and it could be
because regret is so central to our
literally to our brain function that is
our brains don't have a nationality our
behavior can have a nationality because
it's our brains acting in a context but
our but the the lump of of um
of
cells in our head doesn't isn't you know
an indonesian
isn't an indonesian brain or a american
brain or a polish brain it's just a
brain and yeah red is central that makes
sense i mean at the same time there are
so many cultural ideas and memes like
you know fomo fear of missing out yolo
you only live once that aren't the same
across all countries so it would be
interesting whether you know do
brazilians tend to have fewer regrets
than danes versus americans or that type
of thing and it sounds like we don't
really have that data at least at this
point
not at all i mean in fact if you're
talking about the number of regrets i
have no idea because i because in my
surveys i ask people in the quantitative
survey i ask people to list one of their
biggest regrets in the qualitative
survey also
tell me about one big regret i didn't
ask you know so so could there could be
volume differences yeah that people in
in um
in slovenia have lots and lots of
regrets and people in
brazil have only one or two and yet when
you look at the top regrets the biggest
regrets there's commonality there i um
the other thing that is interesting is
whether and you i think you touched on
this in the book a little bit i think
and i've also read articles preparing
for the interview so now i'm not sure
but one of the things is
do more opportunities create an
environment
for having more regrets whereas someone
whose life
felt like it provided fewer
opportunities reduces the amount of
regret that one might feel
yes although opportunity is also
opportunity is a little bit paradoxical
so let me give you let me give you a
piece of data on that from the
quantitative survey the american regret
project the big public opinion poll what
we found there was that people who had
high levels of formal education that is
they had degrees in advanced degrees
right those people um we know which is
which is a minority of of of americans i
think it's something like 30 percent or
so of americans have a college degree
and an even smaller percentage of that
have a so-called advanced degree and
what we found there is that those folks
the people with college degrees and
advanced degrees especially had more
career regrets than other people um
which is weird because
you know that but i but it's it's so
superficially weird but it goes to
exactly to your point which is that the
fact that they had more career
opportunities might have given them a
larger universe of career opportunities
to regret right now that said
thwarted opportunity
can also be a source of regret so
opportunity sort of lives at the core of
regret but in a somewhat paradoxical way
huge numbers of opportunities can lead
to regret but reduced opportunities
can also lead to regret
last thing i want to touch on in terms
of takeaways for one's own thinking and
and actions and sort of life
one principle that i got from the book
maybe rightly maybe wrongly is in
general
there seems to be more regret for things
not done than for things done very very
broadly speaking is that true and and
what other kind of general principles
that one can apply do you think are
important
um it is
what you're saying is
very true i mean that that thing that's
that's a claim that i can make without
with very little hesitation based on the
existing research and based on my own
research and the quantitative survey
that was a very very clear finding
particularly when it comes to age uh
when we're younger we tend to have equal
regrets of
of action things i did and in action
what i didn't do as we age
overwhelmingly it's regrets of inaction
and i think that the takeaway there is
that in general in life we should have a
slight bias for action
that in some ways we're generally over
indexed on risk uh and we're over
indexed on feelings of awkwardness
so we think that asking somebody out on
a date has a high level of risk when it
actually doesn't we think that reaching
out to a friend who's drifted apart it
has high levels of awkwardness but it
really doesn't uh we think and this is a
little bit
closer to the line but but we we
sometimes over index on how much risk it
is to start a business um and and so i
think that a takeaway is that we should
have a in general in life a bias for
action because action is also a way that
it's also a way that we learn things so
i think sometimes we plan too much and
act too little we we feel like in order
to act we have to plan out everything
when in fact
acting itself is a form of planning and
understanding so i think that's one big
takeaway the other big takeaway is i
think in terms of how we reckon with our
regrets is that we should recognize that
when we feel regret it is utterly human
and that when we do that we should treat
ourselves with kindness rather than
contempt recognize that we're it's part
of the human condition we should talk
about our regrets and use language to
make sense of our regrets and we should
explicitly stop and try to extract a
lesson from those regrets so if we do
that if we say you know
this is this is this is what i regret
it's totally normal i'm going to treat
myself with kindness let me try to make
sense of it let me draw a lesson from it
and let me apply that lesson next time
then it's an incredibly productive and
even transformative emotion
the book is the power of regret how
looking backward moves us forward we've
been speaking with the book's author
daniel pink really appreciate your time
today
thanks for having me it was a pleasure
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
i want to be really careful with this
next topic because i bring this up to
you not because i think it's something
to laugh at but it's something to take
seriously
um and to think about in terms of
solving the serious problems that face
the country and that face humanity today
we we now have a sort of combination of
different studies which tell us
something that many of us suspected
intuitively and it's that
on average trump supporters aren't that
smart and i know that this is going to
seem pejorative
and that it is going to make many people
extraordinarily defensive and maybe it's
even going to make people mad at me
but i think that it's not something to
laugh at it's just a phenomenon you know
if the right wants to insist that
intelligence differences exist and of
course intelligence differences do exist
it's just the right likes to insist them
on them along certain lines
then they would have to be open to the
idea that intelligence differences can
exist among
political stripes
and we're going to look at some of that
data right now and then sort of talk
about the implications our our friend
chauncy duvega
has an interesting article a commentary
in salon called new research on trump
voters they're not the sharpest tools in
the box trump's voters lack cognitive
sophistication often believe that the
bible is the literal word of god and in
this article and i encourage you to read
the entire thing chauncey writes as the
new faith in america survey by deseret
news and marist college highlights the
basic
understanding of the role of religion in
a secular democracy has become so
polarized that 70 of republicans believe
that religion should influence a
person's political values whereas only
28 of democrats and 45 percent of
independents share that view okay so
that's a difference on sort of
separation of church and state fair
but
the study goes on to point out
republicans and democrats liberals and
conservatives also don't consume the
same sources of information about news
and politics conservatives now inhabit
their own self-created media echo
chamber which functions as a type of
lie-filled and toxic closed episteme and
sealed off universe the creation of such
an alternate reality is an important
attribute of fascism
and it then goes on to cite research by
darren sherket a professor of sociology
at southern illinois university which
demonstrates that america's democracy
crisis may be even more intractable than
the above evidence suggests in his
article cognitive sophistication
religion and the trump vote
shuriket examined data from 2018 and
concluded there are substantial negative
differences between the thinking
processes and cognition
cognition of white trump voters as shown
in the 2016 presidential election
compared to voters who supported hillary
or another candidate
circuit observed that trump support has
been linked to religion and level of
education but until now not to quote
cognitive sophistication which was found
to have a positive effect on voting
but a negative effect on choosing trump
what that means is
cognitive sophistication as defined in
this study
higher cognitive sophistication makes
you more likely to vote
but less likely to vote for trump
and the article very interestingly
explains
low levels of cognitive sophistication
may lead people to embrace
simple cognitive shortcuts like
stereotypes and prejudices amplified by
the trump campaign
additionally the simple linguistic style
presented by trump may have appealed to
voters with limited education and
cognitive sophistication of course of
course we suspected that
beginning with adorno's classic study of
the authoritarian personality empirical
works have linked low levels of
cognitive sophistication with right wing
orientations
last paragraph and then we'll discuss
trump's campaign may also have been more
attractive to people with low cognitive
sophistication and a preference for low
effort information processing because
compared to other candidates trump's
speeches were given at a much lower
reading level
while much of trump campaigns rhetoric
and orientation may have resonated with
the poorly educated and cognitively
unsophisticated these overlapping groups
are less likely to register to vote or
to turn out in an election you can read
this study
the study is called
cognitive sophistication religion and
the trump vote it's free to read uh on
the wiley online library
and i would encourage you to look at
that so
i mean listen
it's really tough to have this
conversation because anytime you're
saying a particular group isn't as smart
it is seen as pejorative and
understandably so and it is seen as um
offensive in some way and so on and so
forth we had this instinct intuitively
that there's no doubt about that and and
very early on there was data pointing in
this direction we now have some
what i would call evidence or proof
which is on average trump voters are
less cognitively sophisticated they are
more likely to believe untruths look at
the study they are more likely to be
literal believers of some elements from
the bible
i don't see that and laugh like that's
not funny to me i want to solve problems
and one of the things that i've said
many times is when we have to argue
about
this is a shorthand
dumb things
we aren't
arguing about or debating or working
towards solving real and complicated
issues when we have
57 of the republican party believing
that the election was literally stolen
from trump by biden and that trump's the
rightful winner
and we have to you know fend off more
than 60 frivolous lawsuits in court
making that case and all of this
different stuff when we're fighting that
we're not actually fixing other problems
like hey we've got a disastrous
gerrymandering problem in this country
as one example when it comes to voting
when we are arguing about
is there any
of what we are experiencing in terms of
climate change that we can link to the
activities of industrialization and
fossil fuel emissions when we're arguing
about that and some percentage of the
the american public doesn't believe that
we aren't taking steps to actually uh
get off of fossil fuels
and live more sustainably because we're
just trying to argue about the the basis
of fact so
i don't see this and laugh and i know
that it's very easy to just say oh
stupid trump supporters
it's really a much more complicated
issue and it also relates to education
it relates to culture there are
geographical realities here there's
issue about access to
um
education and health care and so many
different things so we should take it
seriously we shouldn't laugh and again
much like the anti-vaxxers for example
they are a danger i mean without a doubt
they are they are a serious danger
and they also are victims of
disinformation to a degree and as
frustrating as we all realize it is to
have to argue with people about no
the vaccine doesn't magnetize you and no
mrna vaccines weren't rushed it's based
on a platform that allows their
development to be faster
as much as we have to argue it's
frustrating to have to explain this
stuff
they are also victims and unless we fix
the mechanism that victimized them to
fall for this stuff it's just going to
keep happening again and again i want to
briefly play a clip for you this maybe
is a little bit different than what we
typically do although not really there's
this band called stained without an e
s-t-a-i-n-d and stain's lead singer is
aaron lewis and i've actually had
run-ins with with this band because they
are from western massachusetts the area
where i grew up as many of you know i
worked at circuit city in holyoke
massachusetts when i was in high school
and uh the the band would often come in
to buy you know equipment equipment they
needed for recording or their home
studios or whatever they were around
they were kind of known entities and and
over the last it hasn't even really been
recent at least 10 years if not longer
the lead singer aaron lewis
has sort of devolved into some pretty
unsophisticated
right wing nuttery and i was quite
shocked to see a clip of him i guess
he's doing performances this is from
just a few days ago where he was almost
in like a conspiracy coma just
everything he said made no sense
whatsoever and one of the scary things
is the the crowd is cheering at some of
the stuff he's saying so listen to this
this is really really bad
you know as it sounds
maybe we should listen to what vladimir
now
why are people cheering about that yes
cheer to listen to putin what maybe just
maybe
when klaus schwab
and george soros
and every other dirty
earth destroying [ __ ]
so he's listing jewish men and calling
them dirty and i know it's not overtly
anti-semitic but when you start talking
deep state and conspiracies and you
start naming jewish men and start using
the adjective dirty
it
it's either anti-semitic or it comes
from an anti-semitic framework and we
know that that to be the case with
frequency
maybe just maybe we should take a good
look at that
why are they trying to protect ukraine
so much
because putin is invading it for
absolutely
no legitimate reason
uh would be a start
do they all have to lose
so a very pro-putin crowd at aaron
lewis's acoustic show
have you seen the pictures with wooden
guns
and
and all the bodies and body bags laying
in the background and
[Music]
he barely has any idea what he's talking
about but he is repeating some
conspiracy theories that have been
floating around
looking elsewhere
[Music]
[Applause]
if you haven't seen
vladimir putin actually say
that he's
fighting the deep state right now which
is the same people we're fighting which
is the same people
everywhere on the face of this earth
that people are fighting
we're all united
against the deep state so you know many
of you know that uh one of the really
common things that the right likes to do
with athletes and entertainers is when
you don't like their politics right when
it's
lebron james or colin kaepernick or
john bon jovi or um i'm trying to think
what other what other but bruce
springsteen
when you don't like their politics it's
shut up and dribble
shut up and sing and play guitar i
didn't pay for you to give me your
political views or whatever but when
they like the substance it's whoa wait a
second we we can't suppress the free
speech of these people
even saying you respect their right to
say it but you don't agree that that's a
suppression on speech now as i've said
before i try to have a consistent view
on this and my view is
anyone who has a platform
of any kind even if it's because you're
good at a sport
or because you're good at singing
or because you're in movies whatever if
you have a platform you have every right
to use that platform
however the hell you want
and others can decide on that basis
whether they want to give you their
money
if you are an athlete and you want to
talk about politics have at it i 100
support people doing that
if i don't like what you say
maybe i choose not to go to your games
right that's it's just my choice and
maybe if i do like what you say i choose
to go steve nash a
former basketball player i believe he's
now a coach
uh canadian um and would often comment
on politics and people say oh he
shouldn't be talk no let him say what
don't go to the games don't go to the
games if you don't like him bruce
springsteen known for his little kind of
political
raps to the crowd in between songs if
you don't like it don't go that it's
that simple green day a band i liked
growing up would often make uh in the
bush era anti-war anti-iraq war
statements
you you bought a ticket
during the during the concert you may
see
melodies played that you do or don't
like you may hear lyrics that you like
or don't like and you may hear political
statements that you like or don't like
use all of that to make a decision as to
whether you want to give your 45 bucks
or whatever it was at the time
uh to green day and that's absolutely
fine but these these blankets shut up
and dribble
play guitar or don't it it's sort of
like when information is leaked
and boat now both democrats and
republicans do this when you have a leak
of information
often elected officials if they like the
substance they'll only talk about the
substance and not how it was obtained
and if they don't like the substance
they'll ignore the substance but talk
about wow this really shouldn't have
been released it's a similar thing with
a lot of these right-wingers on the
athletes celebrities and musicians
commenting on politics i say say
whatever you want i'll decide uh whether
i want to
patronize uh your your business
um or not and it's that simple
today i'm going to have one of my
favorite voicemails ever for you this is
unbel i've never had anything like this
i believe this may be the best series of
voicemails we've received
um a woman
thought
that i said something
and called in and absolutely crushed me
for it
hangs up
realizes
she called the wrong show
and then calls back to apologize you
have to hear this listen to this
can we tell you to go for yourself and
get your ass out of women's business
you're an idiot
and people like you are going to get
strung up and hung you watch it you
watch it son of a [ __ ] cause old
[ __ ] love me aren't gonna put up with
an [ __ ] like you
oh god i despise you you are a punk
you're gonna be somebody's punk in
prison
so i heard that and i thought what on
earth is she talk i don't even know
vaguely what she's talking about
and then i got this voicemail two
minutes later
hey uh kiddo i think i left you the
wrong message
if you're the gentleman on the free
speech station i like you very much my
dear thank you but the person that was
quoted and uh saying that stuff about
women
and trying to act like they didn't know
the judge's name uh capacity brown
jackson's name
it was insulting and i i wanted that
message to go to that guy not to you
sweetie so it you know the message
saying that you're gonna get hung for
that because i am mad at these men
trying to put their noses in women's
business right it's none of their
business you know
so sorry about that i
thought that you that's caption there
was from that person's phone yes um
apology accepted the best
series of calls i have ever received on
this show on today's bonus show we will
talk about the passing of former
secretary of state madeleine albright
we will talk about
the fact that we don't know what's going
on with supreme court justice clarence
thomas who's been missing from the court
for four days now we don't know if he's
still in the hospital we don't know
what's going on and we will talk about
trump's unendorsement of republican mo
brooks all of those stories on today's
bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com and we will see you then
you